yo bootleg cab podcast man special guest
representing Canada yes sir shout out to
Canada man something in the water over
there all the biggest rappers in the
world are from there damn it Nate Husser
what up welcome thank you so you play
basketball yeah that's rapper Hooper
alive are you sure about that absolutely
there's another guy from Canada that's
pretty good who Dax
oh yeah Dax can Hoops I I seen I've seen
him go play in college and [__] he
played for like I think he played for
Wichita State or some [__] I don't know
that's cool so that's a pretty big
Proclamation who's in the realm of best
rapper slash Ballers besides yourself
Chris Brown
uh
he's not quite I mean he's kind of like
he does rapper [__] yeah and he'd be
rapping yeah he'd be rapping he'd be
doing a lot more rapper [__] than most
rappers basically like yeah him I'll put
him up there I know cuevo be hooping
um
shoot a lot of them but I don't think
like I don't think there's many up there
that like like you do this like rapper
like rapper first and Hoover that can
really mess with me so like what is the
extent of your uh basketball like like
did you play college did you like
um I was playing like high school I
played for like inner city teams
um I had a couple scholarship offers to
come play out here but by that time I
had already done chose like music music
so yeah never hockey huh nah you know in
Canada that's kind of the past time
right that's like yeah you do watch it
no not really it's terrible to watch I
don't get it
I mean you know you don't want to [__]
on your country yeah
I watch I just watch I try to watch a
playoff game the other day I was like
what the [__] is like what is I don't
get it it's like a smaller soccer field
unless someone fights
it's fun to play on video games right
yeah like like yeah I feel like FIFA's a
fun game yeah type [__] but I'm not
gonna watch like you know the Major
League Soccer no you know nah anyway
let's stop shooting on the biggest
Sports internationally I'm a big
basketball fan who do you got the heater
the uh nuggets
I want to say the heat
um I was going for the Lakers you know
what I'm saying yeah
workouts exactly but damn Denver's like
they got a crazy strong team like they
got they got joking yeah the Joker uh
any music you got out right now people
can go check out yes I just dropped
itchy palms today is I'll go check that
out music videos out right now shout out
by montreality you know what I'm saying
shots
so yeah I've been checking their
interviews shout out to them so go go
check that out uh album on the way
project on the way project on the way
dark songs to drive to out this summer
There It Is Well let's get right to it
let's go
you know I woke up feeling like you know
what I'm saying smelling like
hey look real life conversations about
billions the dollars I could hear them
sounds so familiar sound like the guy
that I see in the mirror it's me and my
money and your [__] third wheel
nursery rhymes now after my songs it's
emergency Sirens got it in the bag it
started in my mind back pocket full of
Dreams the front was full of Dimes car
talk to me like what the moon slime I
don't use GPS I just follow money signs
look I said I'm here for really no
faking no Philly they see me they hear
they feeling the woman the [__] The
Killers the illness my [__] ain't seen
in a minute I mean forever I could use
some game it was like a million a while
though no Gillies like I'm a millionaire
hello miles from the crib but I'm still
from there I've been a man like
gingerbread now she want me beat it up
like Timberland and we cash it at the
mall used to steal from there you know
gang Gonna Ride Like the city
[__] it I'm a billionaire he a beast I
got dogs I don't give a damn yeah the
Martin on my chain that's my street we
mob like a piece off the leash screaming
[__] Pizza here's a piece on my mind
cause [__] hate for free online but I
don't take back cause I ain't got time
I'm up like birds [__] almost under
me eyeball and I ain't seen them since
they fumbled me I'm married to the money
making company take out the country and
open new company got to change ain't a
thing change I said I fell in love I'm
married to the game room man [__] but I
stay in my Lane around big body The Rock
Dwayne count your blessings run your
money up and don't complain if you're
gonna put a pipe better let it drain man
we don't fear pain know what I'm saying
I spin your block with the streets like
rain yeah I got fans from America to
Africa it's not bad for a former drug
trafficker and even in the Philippines
they feeling me take another out of the
hood I still got the hood of me
[Music]
[Applause]
there it is man let's go hey man go
follow this guy uh what's your IG
everyone's a weirdo
yeah everyone's a weirdo there it is man
appreciate you pulling up brother that
was hard yeah appreciate it man hey I
know you just watched the new freestyle
guess what we're dropping them every
week sometimes more than once a week
Jesus we've been dropping a lot lately
uh shout out to LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week